[MUSIC PLAYING]
Inter-professional
cooperative practice
is very important in
delivering healthcare service.
Introducing kolaboraSIM,
a 360-degree video
learning simulation for
health professionals that
use virtual reality
technology and place
participants in a real
complex teamwork situation
to learn inter-professional
collaborative practice.
[DING]
For our first-round
funding, we collaborated
with Indonesian Young Health
Professionals' Society,
industry-leading a customer
development strategy
to health professionals who
work in inter-professional teams
in rural areas across Indonesia.
The results from
this stage will be
used in designing the scenarios
and developing the simulation
video.
VR simulation for
better collaboration--
kolaboraSIM.